it's breast cancer awareness month so
Intermountain Healthcare the sponsors of
the segment is back to remind you to get
a risk assessment and screening
[Music]
my name is Dr Farrell with Intermountain
Healthcare and October is Breast Cancer
Awareness Month and today I'd like to
talk a little bit about breast cancer
risk assessment and how we do that in
our clinic so breast cancer is actually
the most common cancer diagnosed in
women today it affects one in eight
women there's currently 3.5 million
women living with breast cancer in the
United States I'm just going to take a
listen to your heart so some of the risk
factors for breast cancer are things
that we can change about ourselves like
smoking alcohol use and also our weight
being obese actually puts us at risk for
breast cancer and then there's things
that we can't change so our age is a
risk factor that risk increases the
older we get and there's also genetic
factors that may run in our family that
put us at risk as well so screening is
of critical importance when it comes to
breast cancer the reason for that is the
earlier breast cancer is caught the more
treatable it is in all breast cancer The
Five-Year survival is 90 but that
changes to 98 when it's diagnosed at
stage one and when it's caught later say
stage four that survival decreases to 37
women should begin screening for breast
cancer at age 40 and it should occur
every one to two years and this is for
average risk women women determined to
be at an elevated risk for breast cancer
based on their family history may need
screening at an earlier age than 40. so
when a patient comes into cemia
Intermountain Healthcare what we do for
their breast cancer screening is order a
mammogram a mammogram takes a look at
the breast through x-ray Imaging and
then a physician called the radiologist
reads the images for me to interpret
some signs of breast cancer that I would
be worried about that a patient may
bring to me would be new breast pain or
changes of the breast that is most
important so if a woman notices rashes
or dimpling or nipple discharge all of
that should be brought to my attention a
woman should bring up her medical
history and family history with her
health care provider to determine if
she's considered average risk or high
risk for breast cancer here at
Intermountain Healthcare we take care of
women at all stages of life so be sure
to make your mammogram appointment for
breast cancer awareness month and Beyond
thank you to Intermountain Healthcare
for sponsoring this segment head to
intermountainhealthcare.org Nevada for
more information
[Music]